it's definitely an industry that hasn't
had a lot of disruption and innovation
you know when you go to university today
the way you study is basically the same
as it was 100 years ago some things has
evolved but the learning experience
itself you still have to be the
progressive part my name is Camilla
hazard on last time I am the founder of
Lakes and I'm 25 years old
so Lexus digitizing textbooks for
university students and making them
affordable on a subscription model what
are we working with more in depth is
really you know changing the way
students learn and how they interact
with the content so you don't just have
this old school textbook but you
actually have a more interactive media
and a way of learning what makes looks
different from just a regular textbook
is you have the convenience of having
the books with you everywhere you go you
can use them offline you can take them
into the exams you can watch videos
instead of reading a piece of content
because we all learn different so the
first company I found it went bankrupt
thing I was very young I made all the
mistakes and all that you know when you
open a textbook and you see you know how
to start a company one on one I probably
did everything it said not to do right
there but yeah it cost some money and it
cost some time but I wouldn't be without
that experience because it gave me like
taught me so much in the beginning the
response from the textbook industry
it wasn't very welcoming because we're
doing something very different and this
is a huge market of course they want to
keep their old business models in place
but they could also see that they needed
to do something and there's been a
massive challenge for the publishers to
digitize all their all their content
because piracy was so big and getting
bigger we have provided the publishers
with a very secure platform so they can
feel safe to distribute their content
through us and we know that it's not
going to be pirated and we also make it
more affordable for the students so it's
a win-win
[Music]